en Buenos Aires Argentina se celebró la
séptima cumbre de la comunidad de
Estados latinoamericanos y caribeños
celac Brasil se reincorporó a la Cumbre
bajo el liderazgo de Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva tras tres años de ausencia
durante el mandato el expresidente Jair
bolsonaro que Había decidido ausentarse
por considerar que la celac daba
protagonismo a gobiernos autoritarios
Lula y el anfitrión Alberto Fernández
presidente Argentina propusieron la
creación de una moneda común propuesta
apoyada por Nicolás Maduro presidente de
Venezuela pero rechazada por el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador quien No asistió pero destacó la
importancia de mantener al Dólar como
moneda de referencia la democracia fue
otro punto clave de la conversación
creemos en la democracia
y la democracia
está definitivamente en riesgo
después de la pandemia hemos visto como
los sectores de ultraderecha se han
puesto de pie y están amenazando a cada
uno de nuestros pueblos una Clara
referencia a la sonada los tres poderes
del estado en Brasil el 8 de enero y
ambigua en Casos como el de Venezuela
Aunque la resolución reiteró el rechazo
a la intervención extranjera el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro se
refirió a la guerra en Ucrania y
descartó alinearse con la otan con la
señora Richardson y otras personas de
Estados Unidos ellos me pidieron que
para solucionar el problema de nuestra
incapacidad de sostener esos elementos
activos
se los entregásemos y ellos se los
llevaron a Ucrania
yo le dije que nuestra Constitución
tiene como orden
en el terreno internacional La Paz
y así quedará eso como chatarro en
Colombia no entregábamos las armas rusas
para que se llevaran esos Ucrania a
seguir una guerra la lucha contra el
narcotráfico y el cambio climático
también estuvieron en la agenda así como
la situación de derechos de las mujeres
jóvenes y niñas en la región donde 26 de
los 33 países miembros sufren altas
tasas de feminicidio según la cepal
según la resolución de Buenos Aires la
intención de mayor integración es el
principal objetivo del bloque para el
futuro